I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to another
busy tool video where I highlight some
of the favorite business tools that I
use to run my company so I'm here on my
page which talks about my favorite tools
there's a quick video today on a tool
called g minder so let me just go find
it there's G minor and G minder is
useful if you're making the switch from
Outlook to Gmail
I love the Outlook calendar and had so
much built in there and kind of ran my
business so the gmail calendar I didn't
find as useful especially the reminders
and this little desktop tool is the Vil
for PC maybe for Mac - I don't know
but it basically allows you to have your
reminders pop up on your desktop just
like they would in Outlook so without
this I probably would not have been able
to move over to Gmail and it's too bad G
well doesn't have a version like this
the biggest challenge I had with Gmail
was when a reminder came up you always
had to be online to see it so if you
turn off your computer you went away and
then you came back and there was a past
appointment that came up that you didn't
click off you wouldn't see it so I used
my calendar a lot to record tasks so
could be you know follow up with you
know John about we don't whatever
project we're working on and that task
might stay there for a couple days if I
haven't gotten it done yet so it reminds
me that I still have to do it with
Google Calendar and how it works as soon
as you turn off your computer or go away
it's gone so you there's a whole bunch
of tasks that you may have missed that
you haven't done unless you maybe email
it to yourself
so 4G minder I'll just drag it into the
screen so you can see what it looks like
you have something like this that pops
up and this will keep track of all the
information that you have for the day
and what's coming up so for me you can
see that it's close to 5:45 so got a
reminder here that tells me that I need
to post to my Facebook and Twitter
forums and Google+ so that's helpful and
that'll stay there until I either
dismiss it or close it well basically
dismiss it so I could snooze it or I
could dismiss it now I have
the dunya so I won't dismiss it because
otherwise I'll forget that I have to do
it
so this is great so if I if I turn off
my computer and I come back tomorrow
morning I haven't gotten that done I'll
still see that that's there for me to do
and then I'll see my new stuff as well
just like the way the reminder system
works in a lot so it's an awesome tool
it's free I have the link here on my
site just push that away so you know
definitely go check it out there's a
link here you can load it up and you can
see what it looks like so you just
download it pretty quick
you can also set different days so for
me I only have it set for the one day
but you can also say if you want to see
your schedule for the next few days up
to you how many days you want to add in
you could do it you can quickly add
tasks in there you can do a preview of
what's coming up you can select your
different calendars if you have multiple
calendars which ones you want to have so
I use this for at the office for office
stuff and then I have another one at
home for my home stuff there's different
options here so you can pick the color
you want things that come up you can
pick how quickly the reminder I think
the default without look is 15 minutes
so that's the default here but you can
you know have it change if you want so
the way it'll work is you'll see that
that pop up 15 minutes before and then
it'll pop up again at that time so you
can remind yourself you can play sound
if you want so lots of lots of cool
options and and it's free so no better
price tag for an entrepreneur than free
so hopefully you guys enjoyed that I
definitely check it out of your gmail
user if you liked the video please give
it a thumbs up below I love seeing a
thumbs up that always makes my day and
if you have any thoughts or questions
you can also just leave a comment on the
video I'll be happy to answer them and
thank you for watching and we'll see you
at the next episode
you